today's topic Derick Jack some people
feel like we're not fit enough to you
know counter Derick Jackson that we're
not lifeless I said you know what you're
right so what I did instead was I got
Derek Jackson to argue against Eric
Jackson I was watching a youtube clip
but two girls came to the show I think
there was sisters they had boyfriends
and they were there too as the host what
they should do about they're controlling
boyfriends the boyfriends didn't let
them wear certain things wouldn't let
them go certain places if I do it is
trying to control you that's not cute
that's your cue to leave that's your cue
to run for the [ __ ] heels before it
gets worse
control that's the segue that's the
gateway drug to abuse ladies I know
sometimes when a dude tell you like you
can't do this and you can't do that
y'all be thinking and he just being
controlling but that ain't always the
case if a dude [ __ ] with you it is some
things that he's just not gonna tolerate
own another thing if a dude really loves
you he gonna let you come out the house
or be on social media just any kind of
way
hardly wearing them clothes or being a
pissy drunk like he gonna have none of
that [ __ ] how haha we got to cover this
but a lot of you have also been tagging
me in the post in the story about
Kimbella in Juelz Santana getting
engaged and then I didn't know what we
were dealing with until Kimbella jumped
in the comment section to validate that
yes she's been waiting she even gave you
ladies some advice she said ladies if
that's the man you want in love you will
wait however long if the love is real I
got to address this if you wait for
somebody to seeing you what you've been
sending them for 10 years I'll wait for
somebody to want with you what you've
been wanting with them for 10 years the
love ain't real not the love for
yourself it doesn't take a man who's
diligently working and trying to
progress and trying to grow himself to
be husband already know down 10 years or
anything close to it so good a job so
the other day in Detroit after the event
a girl came up to me asked what she
should do about guys who don't want to
wait to have sex because right now
that's what she knows it's [ __ ] when
I do say he just cannot wait because
really he's saying one of two things
either he doesn't want what you want or
in his eyes you're not worth the wait
and in either case he's not worth the
rush but did
but inch I'm not worthy to contest you
take I don't have the knowledge hell I
don't have the following and apparently
according to some of y'all followers
were jealous of that but now this is not
us talking
this is soldier boy you so so so men
have to wait if we didn't want them to
but women don't have to wait if men want
them to see the way the way mathematics
works that that don't that don't really
make any sense square root of this is
dudu I have a question for you
hey go ahead what you did is go for how
long 20 years now 20 years and when does
a marriage happen after 16 a verse after
16 yeah so you were ready to propose at
that point when you proposed yeah if she
had said hey when you're gonna get this
done it's been 10 years
what would you she never did yeah she
never she was patient through space yeah
and that's probably the reason why I
took my time with it and everything and
stuff like I had other things too I had
other things to work on myself you know
I mean like we started dating was 16
like this I'm not the man that I was
when I was a senior I was not a man so
there's a lot of growth and I'm still
not there
Matt mind you I'm still trying to
improve every freaking date but for that
yeah I took my time with it but
according to Derek this man's
relationship should have never worked by
that point it should have just fizzled
out or whatever but no this is a
conscious decision he made to his girl
when he was ready for it and I just I
think preachers preach is like you know
for me like the opposite he's been with
his girl since he's 16 I've been single
for a very long time now so we have
completely different perspectives but I
have a tremendous amount of respect for
the fact I preach didn't rush anything
he didn't let society dictate how his
relationship was gonna go he said I'm
gonna take it on my own pace with
somebody I know I love and I'm gonna do
when I'm ready and I think that's
beautiful
and that's things people just don't go
in logic like sometimes they were
telling me yeah but by Leia it was ten
years and yet but right now you should
be you should have been proposing so it
was so so so how long ago should I
propose I don't know like five years in
okay so if I started
with her at 10:00 I mean I should have
proposed her when I was 15
nope you was just a time
mine is the time frame some time five
years five years right yeah yeah so
10:15 yeah yeah but then you were too
young to propose oh oh and now I'm old
enough just really just to age 26 day
you suppose that's not how life first no
go to your page do your thing and do it
it's the same thing for success people
like oh you're 28 you haven't figured
out your career some people only make it
when they're 40
some people like Morgan Freeman make it
when they're 50 Jackson right so people
find their success in life at different
stages the same way people find the love
of their life in their marriage partner
at different places there is no rush I
would just tell everyone take your time
you have a lot of growing to do there
isn't societies tell you there's a rush
as a woman decides that y'all your
biological clock is ticking this and
that yada yada yada you may not be at
that place yet where you're ready to be
with that life partner so don't rush it
the question is d how do I make a man
miss me or you know really just regret
letting me walk away or dump him my
answer is the same every single time
just invest energy into yourself stop
focusing on that let it go walk away
blah blah right but if you have to get
something off your chest like if you if
you just have someone your chest as
spiteful espejo it everything is that
you want to call it and you have to get
it off your chest
I would rather you take that route as
opposed to seeking out revenge and if
you're gonna take that route there is a
right way to do it his advice seemed
sound at first hey forget about it move
on better yourself blah blah blah but if
you petty if you petty I'm gonna help
you okay I don't know what kind of like
ready and you know it clap your hands
I'm petty you're not petty okay some
kind of life coach is like yeah be Petty
and resentful and channel your energy I
getting back to people that you want to
cut out of your life I don't know but
maybe it's your life coach move on with
your things but you know what we like
the second part the second part is
cutting him off because guess what a man
wants to tell himself after the
relationship is over here she still
she's still in love with me if I wanted
her back I could have her okay
this is only
true for bad people I would never want
to leave somebody I used to like or
liked right you just because maybe our
relationships not working if I'm leaving
that person I don't want them to linger
on me I don't want them to continue
having feelings for me I don't take
pleasure in knowing that this person has
a hard time sleeping at night or is
heartbroken that doesn't make me happy
any man who's good and feels good
he's garbage and assuming you can get
away from that garbage the better so I
don't know why you were trying to try to
get back at garbage because listen right
the longer that you start playing with
[ __ ] the longer you gonna smell like
like if you think somebody's trash why
would you play in the trash because
maybe you like trash so I'm just trying
to say like that's that's definitely not
true I've never and I mean never left a
relationship thinking you know she's
still into me as [ __ ] dope that's
wack I would say this doesn't really
compromise the curiosity thing really it
actually probably emboldened it but you
need to be hanging with your single
friends out in public
not at the house not eating bonbons not
none of that no Netflix none that you
need to be out and about even if you
don't do clubs make an exception you're
gonna post anything on social media make
sure other dudes are in the picture if
you show your three homegirls so it's
for y'all you need to be four dudes in a
pitcher y'all need to take a group
picture that's it that's not a light
coach as a chunk coach that's the cup
that's the coach of toxicity of our city
of our city because last time I
referenced Beastie Boys BC boys that
someone said someone said oh [ __ ] you
read for his Beastie Boys and now I saw
some of it down
preach you grew up a nvy kid yes and
that I like was just because you know my
life has been [ __ ] no breathing don't
give up if I cut chop
like I remember being high school and
nobody listened to white people music
like [ __ ] like that like this is your
last resort to go to social media to
make someone future that is fat sick
more importantly this life coach is
telling you to not be yourself in order
to get back at somebody who does not
want to be with you not all break up is
a bad thing you might not be ready we're
not in a place where you can be
religious if you are a petty human being
you may not be fit for a relationship
it's like a slow active poison it just
constantly erodes the person that you're
with until they're wither and die like
don't don't don't don't allow bars the
thing that happen while you're doing
your being out of your way to be someone
that you're not and you do spending all
this energy with this person that dumps
you you're doing all that you're gonna
be focused on that person and when mr.
right is actually gonna come around
you're not even gonna see him because
you're gonna be focused on that other
dude
that you try to focus on and try to make
jealous and all of that even worse it's
not that mr. right is she's not gonna
see mr. right mr. right is never gonna
get to see her because she's gonna be so
busy being out of character and not
being herself that he think we look at
him like you know I would not want to
get with that girl even though that's
not who you are but you're too busy
trying to pretend to get back at your ex
that you're not looking ahead you're so
busy being in the rearview mirror and
trying to get back at the person who
honked their horn that you're not
focused on the road ahead of you and
making sure you get to your focus on you
and do you boo boo so the first of
several benefits to dating a woman with
children you know she's the least likely
to be running any of these clubs every
day of the week so not true
nobody I've seen plenty a single mother
I know plenty a single mother single
mothers with their kids in the club yeah
because you know they 30 20 kids 18 I've
seen that because most guys there just
want to come home and smash it she can't
have random dudes coming into her house
that's not true that's not true
that taking for someone who smashed a
single mother - oh yeah I had to walk
quietly by the kids room
and then she's like mommy and I wasn't
gonna sleep [ __ ] look I've been seeing
a whole lot of talk about these new sex
dolls the ones that dudes are telling
women they need to watch out for cuz
they about to take y'all place but I
also saw that these dolls cost $2,000
apiece so my question is why should
women have to worry about a doll that
y'all can't afford the other half y'all
still complain about $200 a month in
child support and you can't even take
the girl that you do like on a real date
to a restaurant that doesn't have a
drive-through who are you
or you want a Netflix and chill with
your homeboys password and then y'all be
talking about splitting it 50/50 with
your woman and that's if you can move
out of your mama's house who are you
talking to sound a lot to me like women
don't need to watch out you dudes need
to humble yourselves cuz women these
days got that bag that is literally none
of the people I know so it says if my
man pays for lunch I'll pay for dinner
if he pays for the movie tickets I got
the snacks if he gets the bill I get the
next 50 50 years where it says stop
expecting to be treated like a queen if
you're not treating him like a king okay
my thought students whenever she's
talking about how she treats a man we
first got to understand that all men are
not the same you know actually I think
there are two types of guys in this
world there's a type of guy that here's
a girl saying something like that and he
says yeah that's right
you are supposed to pay everything 50/50
we are gonna split this down the middle
that's how it's supposed to be check for
tech I pay some you pay some and then
there's a type of guy to hear the girls
say something like that he says you know
what yeah you are supposed to contribute
and add value to the relationship but
when it comes to this providing [ __ ] I
got that isn't it possible that the
reason the woman wants to pay so she
doesn't have to feel like she owes you
anything that's a date
he's are just dogging her though he's
dogging all the men who are fine with
the idea that if a woman wants to engage
in 50/50 and you listen to her you like
you know what lady you got a sound I'm
gonna listen to you all the men who
would let that happen
you're trash listening to what a girl
wants your trench you know there's a
kind of guy that whenever you pulling up
to the house 2:30 in the morning 3
o'clock in the morning middle of the
night with your man and you look in the
house and it looked like somebody in
there something me right and you tap him
to let him know there's a type of guy
that'll say [ __ ] you saw you go check it
out Oh God
you know all men ain't the same all men
ain't one person it's two of them
[ __ ] and I ain't saying there's
only one that you could be in a
relationship or marriage with because
I've seen both of these guys in
relationships of women who said it they
happen and the reason for that is
because there's also two types of women
in this world there's a type of girl
like this that says it's okay if you
only want to pay half the bills I pay
the other half it's okay if you don't
want to pay for the day or even initiate
or plan the day I can do that sometimes
it's okay if you want to play NBA 2k a
fortnight all day on all your off days
at least you got a job that gives you 20
hours a week and pays you minimum wage
and we sitting here financially stressed
out it's okay at least you trying life
is hard and then there's the kind of
woman that says you know what if you get
down I'll hold it down
I'll help us progress that punk we're
trying to be but damn artists gender
reversal gender is redundant we finished
we were City Sen said [ __ ] all this
gender reversal [ __ ] so when he's
talking about women empowerment how
women got the bag now how women are
making money that's empower that's why
that's good gender reversal right but
whenever men have to pay 50 50 whenever
moving to progressiveness like that is
that now I'm I'm empathetic in that I
understand that the dating world is
confusing I understand that it's not
easier to navigate and that for a lot of
women out there they have a hard time
understanding why they're being cheated
on why the relationships aren't working
and they don't know how to navigate men
really well and so here's this
attractive man who seems to be very
upfront he's charismatic and he's saying
things that appeal to you and it's
helping you feel better and so you think
there's some truth to it but when you
really break it down you realize that
this stuff is actually dangerous and my
problem with his advice more than
anything is that not enough of it is
about how much power women have over
themselves within relationships you know
instead of telling you guys what it
needs in you to really work on and how
to self actualize a lot of its just like
a man or trash men are controlling and
all this other stuff men need to wait
which you know alleviates you of your
responsibility but it doesn't actually
solve the problem and you recognize it
what your responsibility in this is and
how much power you have
gives you the strength you need to
actually be better in your future
relationships I think that Derek really
believes he's just doing good things and
I'm sure that for some women he has
actually helped them I'm not nothing to
deny that what I will say however is
that he leaves so far to one side that
there's a lack of balance in what he
says it feels like he all he does is
pamper like why not watching video it
doesn't mean I disagree all the time but
a lot of times it just seems like he's
pandering he said it like that most of
the time if I tell you right you okay
okay yeah and sometimes and it's like in
order to uplift women you don't
necessarily have to put down man and in
necessarily have to alleviate them of
their responsibility sometimes the
answer to their problems is in women
itself meaning that it is take a pause
it's a matter of growth it's a matter of
learning a lesson from a past
relationship it's a matter of you know
actually spending time in the real world
and really just living life and
discovering who you are as a human being
before you can be with somebody else but
the problem is there's no fast solution
to that problem right it takes time it
takes effort and it takes consistency
before you can have that long lasting
relationship and people want to have the
advice that they need today to get to
the relationship and you need tomorrow
but guess what that relations that you
want tomorrow maybe ask you something
you get to discover 10 years down the
line people are getting married at 36 38
39 and it's not because every man before
that is garbage is that maybe you aren't
the person that you need to be do you
know I'm saying you need to be the
relationship yes many like you you learn
some things for your parents you've
learned something to live you have to
unlearn [ __ ] up you need to unlearn
certain things that was given to you by
your parents and by the things around
you you need to unlearn and rewire your
set because there's a lot of problematic
behavior that you have that should
require that you thought that was the
truth but it's not the truth and you
have to rewire yourself into that truth
into okay pastor hey listen my name is
preach and that's for a reason you need
to rewire yourself into that direction
yes you need to have the proper and the
righteous path is it a relationship that
you're supposed to have with the guard
pandering advice that china just puts
all the blame on men in regards to why
your dating life is not successful
because I'm telling you it is not just
men and if you think it is I'm sure I'm
telling you're gonna have a hard time
down the line yeah so just be patient
with yourself I don't know why he's
always in this car all right I don't
know why nobody's seen his legs I don't
know why nobody really seen our legs so
true that's a good point
you show me like I ain't getting up on
there show me like so me really show him
your legs I've seen your Leno show them
you're like no I don't need pressure
from you I'm gonna take my time
[Music]
[Laughter]